-(applause and cheering)
-Thank you very much.
Welcome back.
Now, if you thought America's
lead crisis was limited
to a single town in Michigan,
think again.
The problem in Flint has exposed
a larger lead crisis
around the nation.
And the fact is
that lead is an epidemic,
and if you're anything like me,
you're wondering
how we even got here.
So, luckily, it's time
for a Nightly Show
Super Depressing Deep Dive.
Take a look.
(clicking)
(upbeat videogame music playing)
MAN:
Hi. How are you?
Fantastic. Glad to hear it.
Okay, time for a Nightly Show
Super Depressing Deep Dive.
Everybody knows
that lead is terrible.
When children ingest even
a little bit of lead,
it causes brain damage,
seizures, even death.
And death is one
of the worst things
that can happen to a child.
Even worse than being forced
to wear a onesie
for a band your dad likes.
Hey, dads,
babies don't like Wilco.
-(baby crying)
-Nobody likes Wilco.
Anyway, lead is terrible,
but it's also everywhere.
To find out why
we have to travel
all the back back to 1904,
Australia.
See, in 1904,
Australian investigators
realized that children
in lead-painted homes
were showing the same symptoms
as sick
factory machinists
who worked with lead all day.
Soon the Australians published
their findings,
and everybody could read
about how dangerous lead was.
(loud gasping)
Cut to 1922
when the League of Nations
tried to ban lead paint
worldwide.
The band worked, lead paint was
outlawed, and everything was
-sunny and happy again.
-CHILDREN: Yay!
-Back to you, Larry.
-(scream, explosion)
Just kidding. Life is
an ever-churning maelstrom
of avarice and pain,
and this story is no different.
(woman screams)
See, the U.S. didn't ban lead
paint until 1978.
Why did it take more
than 50 years
for the U.S. to do anything
about lead paint?
-If you guessed corporate
greed... -(bell dinging)
- ...you win the trophy.
-(baby crying, angels singing)
-Just don't chew on it.
It's made of lead. -(coughs)
The U.S. didn't sign on to the
1922 ban because of lobbying
by pro-lead groups like
the Lead Industries Association
and the National Paint, Varnish
and Lacquer Association.
That's the N.P.V.L.A.,
or "NuhPuhVLa," for short.
♪ NuhPuhVLa! ♪
And in that time,
not only was lead paint legal.
It was actively marketed
to young people.
Companies would even send out
lead-paint coloring books
to households with children.
In fact, take a look
at the Dutch Boy mascot.
Fun, cartoony. Kind of reminds
you of this dude, doesn't he?
-(coughing). Aw.
What was the deal with that?
In fact, in 1938,
the government even mandated
that cheap lead-based paints
had to be used
in certain government
housing projects.
Congratulations!
You have just survived
the Depression.
What are you gonna do next?
I'm gonna saddle
my entire family
with a lifetime of incurable
neurological problems!
So, like big tobacco, the lead
industry fought warning labels,
promoted junk science
and went after their critics.
In the 1950s,
they even threatened
to sue the makers of the show
Highway Patrol
for their episode
about lead poisoning.
NARRATOR: Little Tommy Norton,
gravely ill
and without medical aid,
was unable
to understand
the strong and gripping pains
that wracked his body.
MAN:
Ooh, that sucks.
-(angels singing)
-Sorry, Little Tommy.
Anyway, cities didn't start
taking action until much later,
with New York banning
lead paint in 1959.
In the '60s, it fell
to community groups
to educate residents
about the dangers of lead.
Community groups like...
the Black Panthers.
That's right,
those Black Panthers.
The same Black Panthers
your mom's friend on Facebook
thinks are gonna break
into her house
and force-feed her chicken
and waffles. -(woman screams)
Those Black Panthers were way
ahead of the federal government
on the dangers of lead.
The Black Panthers ran
People's Free Medical Clinics.
That,
among many other services,
provided lead tests
for their communities.
Now I know the Black Panthers
did bad stuff.
(baby crying)
♪ Bad stuff! ♪
But testing their communities
for lead--
-that's definitely in the
pro column. -(siren blaring)
So, scientific evidence
about the dangers of lead
was mounting,
and you know what that means.
Time to blame the victims.
The lead industry
actually claimed
that the real danger was from
uneducable Negro
and Puerto Rican parents
who couldn't stop their kids
from eating paint.
Uneducable Negro
and Puerto Ricans?
Yeah, well, maybe all
the Negroes and Puerto Ricans
were uneducable because
you turned their brains
into crème brûlée
with your toxic paint,
you evil mother (bleep)!
-(woman gasps) -Sorry. Sorry.
Back to monotone narration.
In 1978, the United States
finally banned
the sale of lead paint,
-and lead pipes were banned in
the 1980s. -(children cheering)
-But the damage was done.
-(organ plays gloomy tune)
Lead was already tied
into millions
of poor urban neighborhoods.
It was part of the family.
-(children giggling)
-And it impacted real people
like Freddie Gray, whose death
at the hands of the police
touched off unrest
in Baltimore last year.
MALE REPORTER:
His mother and stepfather
raised Freddie and his siblings
in a home so squalid,
they won a settlement
from the landlord
over lead paint exposure.
WOMAN:
They made the connection
to problems
he ultimately had in school.
I first read about it,
and I thought,
how am I even talking
about lead paint
and we're talking about,
you know,
we've lost this young man,
but it's all connected.
That's right, pretty
white lady, it's all connected
in the great circle
of (bleep) over poor people
and minorities.
I know it's upsetting,
but that's why
it's not called the...
It's called...
Everything is awful.
Have a nice day.
-(audience groaning)
-Well, that was depressing.
We'll be right back.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)